Let's use our idea of perimeter to solve this problem. The length of a rectangle
is 6 feet more than its width, and the perimeter of that rectangle is 52 feet.
What are the dimensions, length and width, of the rectangle? To start this
problem, let's draw a diagram. Here's a rectangle, with a width and a length.
Notice the opposite sides of the rectangle are the same. This is true for all
rectangles. Before we answer this question, let's break our problem down into a
smaller step. Let's start with an equation. So I want you to write an equation
for the perimeter of the rectangle. Use p for the perimeter, l for the length,
and w for the width. Write your equation in this box. Remember, equations have
an equal sign, expressions don't.